avec Uncharted, je tournais des cascades
bien plus importantes que tout ce que j'avais
fait avant
la séquence lorsque nous volions à l'
arrière de l'avion sur les boîtes, je veux dire, nous avons
dû filmer ça pendant cinq semaines
presque tous les jours, parfois je'  J'étais comme à
cent pieds dans les airs, attaché à une
boîte qui tournait, puis je
m'accrochais jusqu'à ce que cela
me déstabilise
et c'était vraiment effrayant, mais je pense que ce
niveau de peur rend cette scène encore
plus authentique.  la
séquence d'action la plus difficile que j'ai jamais réalisée j'en
ai rêvé toute ma
vie le trésor d'aujourd'hui qui n'a jamais été
trouvé
cinq milliards facile
oh mon dieu je suis vraiment désolé merci il y a
500 ans ma famille a trouvé une fortune
puis a été trahie
alors  beaucoup de sang, je suis
presque sûr qu'il a juste menacé de
me tuer ne touche pas ton oreille comme ça tu
ressembles à un idiot inexploré exclusivement
dans les salles de cinéma
c'est le plus gros trésor qui n'a jamais
été trouvé
cinq milliards facile le 18 février ma
famille cherchait ce marché
pendant très longtemps, tellement de sang Tom
Holland
oh mon dieu tu es sur le point d'avoir un bon
accueil écossais
quoi
[Musique]
Tom Holland et Mark Wahlberg dans
Uncharted nous ferions mieux de devenir plus petits et d'accord
plus petits, ils ne font qu'un pouce de
plus que  moi je pense que c'est un peu
plus que ce gamin en exclusivité au ciné le
18 février
toi